hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
hier auf einem kanal
es ist wieder recht spät ist es gerade
halb zwei in der nacht fakt ist dass
wirklich total spielt aber ich bin
gerade endlich fertig geworden mein pc
endgültig zusammenzubauen und ihr seht
schon oh mein gott luca die heftigsten
schildern dies gibt ich glaube dass ein
ultra shader auffahren und ich habe
trotzdem irgendwie 120 fps weil neue pcs
nun da ich werde mal kurz in den dichten
wechseln so ich habe welche shader habe
ich drin ich weiß gar nicht ich habe mir
hier die 1.4 punktsieg wieder eingepackt
und habe jetzt hier ganz ganz viele
shader ich kann es auch einfach mal auf
die hier wechseln zum beispiel dass auch
wir noch mal ein paar andere und es
läuft halt wirklich alles total flüssig
auch wenn ich mit so einem 64er texture
pack spiele ich kann das ganze jetzt
auch mal irgendwie ich mach das mal
wieder zurück auf die version mit der
ich wohin gespielt hat es ist halt
einfach total genial dass das jetzt
alles so funktioniert wie ich mir das
vorgestellt habe und der pcs um endlich
angekommen und das ist eigentlich nur
ein kleines update video da er ja die
mindset folge die ich nachts gedreht
habe und da relativ ruhig dann
gesprochen habt ihr eigentlich ganz gut
beziehungsweise kamen ganz gut an
und da hab ich mir gedacht dass ich hier
mal wieder ein bisschen aufnehmer meiner
alten letscho welt bzw nicht alt sondern
dazwischen da gesehen und da seht ihr
auf was neues moment moment da kommt
noch was neues sind also ich bin da noch
so manchmal am bauen also vielleicht
kommt dabei etwas hier kommt auch noch
das hin
die sache ist jetzt allerdings dass mein
neuer pc da hast du dich freue mich
einfach nur total weil mir ein alter pc
man imac den werde ich jetzt verkaufen
möglich möchte ich mal ganz kurz den
mond da hinstellen ich glaube wo geht
der mond auf der geht da auf da geht
erst mal die sonne unter her da geht die
sonne unter das ist total schön dass die
sonnenstrahlen wirklich von diesen
bäumen so ein bisschen dann ist es
dunkel ist jetzt wieder ein bisschen
heller aber wir beobachten jetzt einfach
mal den wohnt aufgang oder bin ich auch
noch ein bisschen weg und muss auch noch
weiter bauen wir beobachten jetzt
einfach mal den mondaufgang von ich
glaube von hier sollte man das ganz gut
sehen oder für mich eigentlich noch
besser mit strahlend und so lief ich auf
ein wirken weil das ist das was ich
meinte dass ich mir die shader wenn ich
die dann benutzen kann
also wenn ich die fähigkeit habe nicht
ich sein moment computer die fähigkeit
hat das denen die shader zu benutzen
dass ich sie dann noch benutzen werde
ich weiß ich war damals immer contra
steht aber dass es nur weil man die
jetzt viel besser konfigurieren kann und
das habe ich nun gemacht dass gerade
gesehen ich hab so ganz ganz viele
shader dateien drin
ich habe jetzt hier die
lichtverhältnisse lichtverhältnisse
spanischer lichtverhältnisse ein
bisschen umgestellt so dass jetzt zum
beispiel der mond ihr seht dass der
macht solche spielen also wenn ich jetzt
hier mal so ein bisschen gucke ihr seht
dass in solchen spielen an den blättern
also der mond breiter so ein bisschen
das sind so ein sub so strahlend seht
ihr die ich weiß nicht wie das sieht man
vielleicht ja jetzt sieht man es ganz
gut der mond prallte so ein bisschen den
bäumen ab das habe ich halt eingestellt
und auch das zb hier sehe ich es ist
relativ hell und hier ist relativ dunkel
das heißt hier wenn man hier wirklich
hinter dem baum ist passiert nichts wenn
ich jetzt allerdings habe dann scheint
der mond nicht richtig an und das ist ja
in wirklichkeit auch so dass der mond
dann schon ein bisschen strahlt hier
unten habe ich damals man klosters drin
gehabt allerdings geht die beleuchtung
da trotzdem ich weiß nicht warum aber
allgemein finde ich so das haus erkennen
dass er noch beim einhalten der showwelt
das ist wunderschön mit den shader nicht
konrad ich komme da gar nicht auf
wahrscheinlich dass man warte ich kam
rein laufen
das ist wunderschön texture pack ist
zwecks übrigens ganz anders texture pack
ändern
lustig finde ich auch mal noch sehr
schön vor allem mit den schildern
jeweils nicht oft lustig das war diesen
teil wo im klaren so hier damit finde
ich das haus sieht auch wunderbar aus
mit denen mit dem event and action pack
finde ich alles wunderschön weil es mit
dem schädel ich kann jetzt echt tausend
jahre lang ihren posaunen wie toll ich
das doch finde aber was auch ganz geil
ist diese mond spiegelung einfach im
wasser die kommt wenn der mond gleich
wieder weiter oben ist dann seht ihr das
wieder mehr
ich gehe mal wieder zurück auf die ford
kann ich eigentlich auch mal zeigen die
vollzieht dann halt so aus dass auch die
vollzieht damit ein bisschen besser aus
allerdings finde ich dann wenn ich
spiele dann spielte zwecks weil zwecks
finde ich da spiele ich auch ein biest
und so mache ich eigentlich nicht zwei
sachen pvp sache immer default aber ich
denke ich werde dann ob man manchmal den
shader benutzen
zwar nicht die ins wasser und ich habe
so eine richtige allein dieser dieser
blick schwierig durch das man an dieses
wasser bewegt macht das einfach nur
schön
gefällt mir was mittlerweile so alles
möglich ist also das wollte ich noch
ganz gut sagen dass mein pc angekommen
ist an alle die gefragt haben welche
daten deren hat das ist eine nvidia
geforce gtx 680 als grafikkarte von
gainward das ist so gaming glaube ich
ich habe 16 gigabyte arbeitsspeicher ich
habe einen intel core i7 quadcore
prozessor ich habe einen samsung
syncmaster es 22 b 350 zweimal habe ich
den also auch noch einen zweiten
bildschirm ist perfekt der bildschirm
kann empfehlen ich habe oder in teams am
mikrofon behringer 10x 1002 mischpult
razer mamba als moslem roccat isku als
tastaturen iphone 5 im zersplitterten
bildschirme 10 die muskeln sonst noch
sagen towers eigentlich scheißegal ich
habe ihnen fern wenn man von maschinen
playstation auch noch wlan habe ich auch
noch drin stehen ein schweif total ab
naja ich hab halt jedenfalls zum pc
genommen das worauf wir beim pc
lediglich am meisten achten müssen ist
die grafikkarte weil sich das entwickelt
sich wirklich am schnellsten weiter und
prozessor auch also prozessor kann ich
nur sieben quad core intel empfehlen
inter grafikkarten habe ich auch bisher
nur gute erfahrungen mit ich hoffe das
bleibt so aber geht die x86 läuft ganz
gut und ich kann er mit battlefield auf
ultra mit 130 ps spielen
die habe ich jetzt auch eine menge fps
rate nicht mehr f3 drücke seht ich habe
gerade 20 30 fps aber das ist auch weil
fraps das ganze auf 30 fps unterstellt
trotzdem geht das schon höre das heißt
nämlich was da dies gut mit stadt ist
gut so hier sind ein paar sachen dazu
sein hafen werden hab ich mir gedacht
immer bei meinen cousin hier ist warum
er so ein bisschen weiter weil wir dann
irgendwie immer so minecraft zocken die
komplette nacht wenn du das hier gerade
guckst sei gewiss david
ja man mich dass alles so geil einfach
ich finde das klasse
ich finde es super mit den schildern
schreibt die kommentare wie euch das so
gefällt ob wir auch mit shader spielt
oder eher nicht so und naja also jetzt
kann einfach nur langweilig jetzt um die
uhrzeit ich bin nicht mit relativ viele
sachen getrunken haben so in richtung
die wand morgen kauflandes fensterladen
da muss erst mal in der schulzeit an
irgendwie ändern sie trinkt und so was
alles geholt also etwa auch nicht so
toll dass man zu trinken oder so wolf
aber naja kann ich darauf klar ist nicht
so schön aus davon war jetzt erstmal
screenshot sieht nicht so gut aus
also ich bin gerannt ich spritze gleich
darauf ab dass doch noch mal was das
hier findet eine grafik ist brauch 9
gefragt ich liebe dich da sind auch
tintenfische klasse sorgt 1000
screenshots machen
naja also freunde ich wollte euch nur
sagen ist mir neue pc parteitag kapital
und gar nicht gesehen mache ich mir
eigentlich so sieht das ganze welt um
ist bei tag hatte ich ja wieder die
anderen schäden während mittag hatte ich
glaube ich hat sich die welt tag ja
genau die hatte ich wette aktiv war
nicht bei kann mich eigentlich ganz gut
also der tag sieht das hier alles ein
bisschen besser aus ein bisschen
plastischer vor allem diese blöcke sind
normal so ineinander aufgeteilt also das
finde ich bei tag eindeutig besser wenn
ich erzählt im wald gehe und so alles
möglich also finde ich auf jeden fall
sehr cool müsste ich dann entweder immer
wechseln oder mal schauen wie das dann
sich so entwickelt und was ich jetzt
auch mal ausprobiert ist ein komischer
shader guckt euch mal bitte den an höhe
das habe ich auch so ein bisschen
rumprobiert kann man ja auch mal machen
also ich nicht interessiert vielleicht
versucht er noch ein paar sachen
umzusetzen
und ja meine lieben freunde dann würde
ich einfach sagen wenn es euch gefallen
hat dürfte gern ein daumenbruch gehen
wenn ihr euch genauso wie ich nicht
gerade freue weil jetzt endlich mal ein
paar schilder sachen kommen ich versuche
dann auch bei fiete wies shader 1 zu
bauen jetzt in der nächsten
aufnahmesession weiß noch nicht wer
heute abend kommt ja noch eine folge das
wasser sieht hier aber auch cool aus
bewegt sich auch so witzig na ja heute
am computer erfolgt ich weiß noch nicht
ob das shader drin sind weil eine höhle
ich muss halt schauen ob ich das ganze
installiert kriege ich muss allgemein
ist - rein kriegen aber das ganze ist
alles schon so normal läuft und alles
ist wundervoll
das ist richtig klasse danke dass ihr
mir das ermöglicht haben durch das
fleißige kommentare schreiben werbung
klicken und so was alles dass ich mir
das hier kaufen kann und für euch
investieren kann so dass er ein besseres
gefühl haben sie werde ihren besseres
ankucken ihrer sich deshalb auch schön
aus
ein bisschen ich freue mich einfach mal
so ein bisschen mit euch doch alles
wunderschön aus also ich finde das alles
gerade total klasse e mc schon richtig
ich mich richtig freue ich kann mich an
keinen einblick geben in lecce part 2
wenn ihre partei nicht gesehen habe dass
es gibt auf einem kanal in schulen
einfach world of warcraft oder youtube
suche ist eine kleine quelle ich weiß
nicht wie die letzten auch schon acht
die schwimmt ja auch das ja niedlich
hier wird eine farm entkommen
dahinter da habe ich nämlich schon platz
macht egal da komme ich aber gleich zu
also dass er jetzt noch nicht das wetter
so wegnehmen will ich gerade so erwarte
ich muss hier wieder auf den weg finden
so hier kommen aus dem weg raus dann
kommt hier dem kleinen markt sicherlich
das alles genauer zeigen dass noch zum
brandmeister sky
oh mein gott sich das geil aus bereich
keine 1000 screenshots machen sorry
leute aber das sieht auch so hammer aus
hier ist noch ein paar mehr häuser hin
mich das schon ein paar pyramiden mehr
gebaute fast gar nicht jeder hinten habe
ich aber noch ein dorf entdeckt
das sieht der wald woran der uns also in
brand gesetzt hat dieser und also ich an
die farben hin dass dieses fahren
gebäude doppel form hin
dabei wirken ein bisschen weiter gebaut
habe ich allgemein ruhe hier habe ich
hier wollte ich noch den weg lang legen
an jeder weg geht ja hier extra so
runter damit das haus hier alles auf
einer höhe ist genau ich hab so ein paar
kleinigkeiten die verbessert wie zb der
weg oder das viel sand erde ist anstatt
sand das ist doch blöd dass die garage
ist nicht auf einer höhe wie weg so aber
hier kommt dann seinen weg lang so
weiterhin kalt hier so hoch und darum
wollte ich dann sein restaurant hin
bauen
da kann man hier einfach so hoch ist wie
im restaurant so über die ganze sache
natürlich nur noch schöne ausblick also
um fünf minuten gequetscht einfach nur
ja ja mit diesem tollen anblick mitten
in den vorgarten hier von unserem pool
bereich von meinem häuschen will ich
sagen es euch gefallen hat wie schon
gesagt daumen hoch kenne meine
kommentare schweinberg dazu gefällt
vielleicht doch noch ein paar neue ideen
für die novelle da ist noch alles
relativ kalt und dann will ich sagen
will ich mich jetzt hier noch ein
bisschen dafür die textur
das ist natürlich blöd und das sind
vorhanden ist versteht ist kurz an habe
ich die falsch angebracht ich weiß nicht
ist halt so gut vorne nämlich sagen wird
den nutzern einfach beim nächsten mal
bis 21